le Conseil Général de la Réunion vous
présente lien social le Conseil général
aux côtés des Réunionnais
sauvage et pas du tout modifié par la
main de l'homme c'est aussi grâce à ces
espaces appelés ens pour espace naturel
sensible que la Réunion fait parler
d'elle à travers le monde une richesse
si unique que l'île a été inscrite au
patrimoine mondial de l'humanité par
l'UNESCO pour plus de 40% de sa
superficie une preuve incontestable
qu'il faut préserver ses espaces
naturels sensibles propriétés du conseil
général mais il n'est pas question pour
autant de faire de ces espaces des
musées fermés au contraire le Conseil
général souhaite que la population se
les approprie en pouvant les découvrir
alors comment préserver ces endroits
tout en les partageant on en parle
maintenant dans lien social
c'est dans cette forêt du sud de l'île
qu'une équipe d'homme courageux et
volontaire travaillent ils ont pour
objectif de rendre cet endroit dans son
végétation accessible à toute la
population réunionnaise et au touriste
c'est une mission particulièrement
difficile car le lieu qu'ils aménagent
est un espace naturel sensible riche en
espèces endémique ils doivent faire en
sorte de valoriser le lieu sans abîmer
la végétation cette équipe met du coeur
à l'ouvrage car pour ses ouvriers ce
n'est pas un simple travail il s'agit de
valoriser un endroit qui fait partie du
patrimoine réunionnais le piton mont
vert
c'est la découverte du python c'est
faire connaître faire prendre conscience
aux gens que ce python existe il est là
on peut faire si on peut faire ça il y a
pas une chose à faire quoi on ne coupe
pas les arbres à proprement dit on coupe
des arbres quand on a besoin pour
aménager des escaliers pour aménager
des endroits où les gens viennent
et emprunte ses sentiers ou ses chemins
pour que eux retrouvent là
quelque chose d'agréable quoi le
ressenti c'est de mettre en valeur le
python
c'est quand même un patrimoine qu'il
faut préserver et nous les lapins
richesse et ça il faut
il faut que le Réunionnais et le
tourisme prennent conscience que ça
c'est un site qu'il faut préserver
si on est là aujourd'hui à se donner
pour le mettre en valeur
c'est que ça perdure dans le temps et
que les générations futures puissent en
profiter au mieux possible
au-delà des missions d'entretien et
d'aménagement ces équipes ont pour
objectif d'anticiper les difficultés
après des périodes de pluie de préserver
et de faire un suivi sur les espèces
végétales et animales un programme riche
et indispensable pour donner envie au
public de s'y rendre tout en préservant
le mieux possible l'état du site on
prévoit pas le travail du joueur le pôle
lendemain c'est un travail qu'on voit
directement sur le temps on arrive le
matin et c'est là on voit directement le
travail vu qu'ici on peut pas vraiment
prévoir le travail vu que par rapport au
temps par rapport les impacts des
personnes quand il vient juste sentier
il fait que le travail c'est la plupart
du temps il y a toujours à 5 personnes
pour contrôler le sentier c'est aller
marches on fait les rondes pour vérifier
qu'il y a pas de danger pour les
personnes des branchements qui
pourraient tomber sur les visiteurs
toujours de la surveillance surveillance
contre le braconnage surveillance aussi
pour en cas s'il y a des personnes qui
veulent mettre le feu ou
casser les arbres ou quoi que ce soit et
le suivi le suivi sur tous les espèces
qu'il y a que ce soit exotique ou des
orchidées on fait des suivis bien
réguliers dessus pour voir les
évolutions des plantes ou quoi que ce
soit
au-delà de la vision écologique
l'entretien et l'aménagement de ces
espaces qui appartiennent au conseil
général ont aussi un intérêt social car
il permet de créer beaucoup d'emplois en
soutenant financièrement les
associations et les organismes qui
gèrent ces sites le Conseil général
participe activement à la préservation
des ENS tout en créant des emplois la
gestion des ENS aujourd'hui très
importante pour la population
réunionnaise puisque 750 à 800 contrats
et des sons répartis en notre partenaire
ONF et gestion de nos espaces naturels
sensibles et ça apporte du travail à la
population aujourd'hui alors les
weekends nature permettent à la
population réunionnaise de mieux
comprendre et de mieux s'approprier
notre nature ça permet aussi
lors de cette occasion de de faire une
sortie familiale conviviale pour
découvrir est préservé notre espace
naturel sensible et nos forêts
départementaux dominiales pendant le
mois d'octobre ce sont 23 sites qui
seront ouverts au public sur toute l'île
et sans programme de visite gratuite qui
seront ouverts au public j'invite donc
tous les Réunionnais à consulter le site
internet du Conseil Général pour
s'inscrire pour ses visites
la richesse de ces espaces naturels
sensibles fait de la Réunion un endroit
unique au monde le Conseil Général
continue de soutenir tous les acteurs
des ENS qui se battent pour faire de
notre département un endroit original de
par sa biodiversité et ses espèces
endémiques à découvrir durant les
week-ends
tout le mois d'octobre
le Conseil Général de la Réunion vous a
présenté lien social le Conseil général
aux côtés des Réunionnais